[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présente le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
comme tous les lundis bonjour Yve merci
d'être avec nous directeur adjoint de la
rédaction du Figaro ça va bien et
vous-même bien et Catherine tricot est
avec nous bonjour Catherine merci
également d'être là rice de la revue
regard on va parler avec vous de la loi
immigration elle arrive lundi prochain
ici au Sénat hier Olivier marlex a
accusé Gérald haranin de mentir de
présenter un texte avec des fausses
mesures de droite alors le ministre de
l'Intérieur réussira-t-il à convaincre
les républicains et à trouver un
compromis vous nous direz ce que vous en
pensez et puis Samia on va revenir avec
vous sur une autre annonce d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est inscrit livg dans la
Constitution oui on viendra sur le long
parcours législatif de cette proposition
ce sera à suivre tout de suite dans le
club d'abord on regarde l'actualité dans
nos
régions
[Musique]
et l'info dans nos régions ce matin
c'est cette hausse du tarif de l'eau à
laquelle on assiste un peu partout en
France à Redon en î et Villaines une
hausse de 18 % a été voté alors pourquoi
le prix de l'eau augmente c'est la
question à laquelle a tenté de répondre
Flora sauvage en se rendant à Redon l'or
bleu n'a jamais aussi bien porté son nom
à l'image de nombreuses villes en France
l'agglomération de Redon en île et
villenes a voté une hausse de 18 % de
son tarif de l'au le montant de la
hausse pour un habitant de la ville de
renaon pour prendre l'exemple le plus
important de hausse se situe au niveau
de 70 € par an pour une facture de 80 m³
une hausse dû à la nécessité de financer
des travaux de rénovation des
installations car depuis trop longtemps
les investissements dans les réseaux
d'eau ont été insuffisant ce qui
fragilise ses infrastructures
l'abonnement à la part fixe en
particulier est très utile pour pour
financer les travaux et surtout financer
la construction d'une nouvelle usine de
production d'eau potable avec des coûts
que nous avions estimés au départ à
entre 5 et 6 millions d'euros et qui
aujourd'hui du fait de renchérissement
des travaux publics sont estimés d' 8 9
millions d'euros à cela s'ajoute
l'explosion du prix des réactifs utilisé
pour purifier l'eau ici à Redon l'eau du
canal de nantabrest est prélevé pour
ensuite être traité afin de la
transformer en eau potable on a des
pompes qui nous prennent l'eau dans le
canal et remontent sur la station et
après on part en gravitation sur l'usine
pour traiter de l'eau avec différents
stades de traitement on injecte du
chlorur FÉRIQUE du lait de chaud du CO2
on rajoute aussi du charbon actif en
poudre pour traiter les pesticides en
amont mais le prix du chlore comme du
charbon actif ne cesse de grimper et
c'est sans compter les machines et les
pompes très énergivores qui sont
nécessaires au traitement de l'eau dans
les stations des uration ce qui fait
exploser la facture on oxygène l'eau
pour alimenter des bactéries et ces
bactéries là dégrade la pollution
c'està-dire abadement du nitrate et de
l'ammoniaque ce qui consomme beaucoup
d'énergie en fait c'est la production
d'air pour oxygéner les bactéries dans
le bassin ça c'est c'est 75 % de la
consommation de l'énergie de
l'installation à Redon comme ailleurs en
France la facture d'eau augmente pour
les usagers et les tarifs devrai
continuer de
grimper ettherine mod de réaction
puisque vous avez une autre casquette je
l'ai pas précisé mais vous êtes
également urbaniste c'est vrai et ben je
je enfin je pense qu'il y a une vraie
question sur l'eau il va falloir réparer
les tuyaux il va falloir assurer à
chacun un minimum de mè CUB d'eau à un
tarif très accessible mais je pense
qu'il y a aussi une autre mesure plus
structurelle c'est de de réfléchir à
l'utilisation qu' l'on a de l'eau
potable c'està qu'on n'est pas obligé
d'arroser les parcs et jardins de
nettoyer les rues et de mettre de l'eau
potable dans nos machines à laver nos WC
donc peut-être qu'on pourrait faire
évoluer la législation et autoriser
comme c'est le cas par exemple à Paris
les parcs et jardins sont utilis sont
arrosés avec ce qu'on appelle de l'eau
brute c'estd de l'eau non traitée ou en
tout cas très peu traitée donc je pense
qu'il y a vraiment une réflexion à avir
sur l'utilisation de notre eau très
filtrée très traité de façon à ce que ça
ne renchérisse pas le coût pour tout un
chacun c'est un peu commen ça à faire
Emmanuel Macron avec son plan haut de
réfléchir à une autre utilisation de
l'eau oui tout à fait mais voilà ce que
je pense c'est que ça doit devenir un
débat public on a vu qu'il a un gros
conflit sur les méabassines euh je pense
qu'il y a voilà il y a matière à
réfléchir sur l'utilisation de l'eau qui
nous tombe du ciel et comment on la
récupère et comment on l'utilise on n
pas obligé de tout filtrer on va passer
au premier débat de ce club et c'est
cette annonce hier d'Emmanuel Macron ça
bien Emmanuel Macron qui a donc dit qu'
voulait inscrire l'IVG dans la
Constitution oui c'est sur les réseaux
sociaux hein que l'a annoncé hier le
président de la République un projet de
loi constitutionnel sera déposé avant la
fin de l'année au Conseil des ministres
en 2024 la liberté de femme de recourir
à l'IVG sera irréversible à sur le chef
de l'État alors inscrire le droit à
l'avortement dans la Constitution c'est
un engagement qu'il avait déjà pris le 8
mars dernier pour la journée
internationale des droits des femmes en
réalité le travail parlementaire a déjà
commencé depuis longtemps sur le sujet
puisquen novembre 2022 l'Assemblée
nationale avait adopté une proposition
de loi constitutionnelle déposée par la
France insoumise elle a ensuite été
votée par le Sénat en février dernier
mais avec une modification à apporté par
le sénateur les républicains Philippe
Bas dans la version du Sénat ce n'est
pas un droit mais une liberté d'avorter
qui aurait été inscrite dans la
Constitution et normalement ce texte
aurait dû revenir en 2ème lecture à
l'Assemblée à la fin du mois de novembre
mais c'est donc l'exécutif qui reprend
la main oui et c'est en fait ce que
demandent depuis longtemps les
parlementaires de gauche parce que la
proposition de loi de la France
insoumise elle aurait dû être approuvée
par un référendum c'est la règle quant
une modification de la Constitution est
proposée par le Parlement et même si une
majorité de Français est favorable à
cette mesure la gauche chez les
associations craignait surtout les
effets d'une violente campagne anti-IVG
à l'occasion d'un référendum donc il
demandait à l'exécutif de déposer un
texte gouvernemental parce que quand un
projet de loi vient du gouvernement il
n'y a pas besoin de référendum pour
modifier la Constitution ça peut-être
fait devant les députés et les sénateurs
réunis en congrès à condition d'avoir
une majorité des 3/5è des parlementaires
et Samia c'est donc une victoire pour
les défenseurs du droit à l'avortement
oui les associations le réclamai la
gauche aussi se réjouit a commencé par
la France insoumise et ce n'est pas tous
les jours qu'elle est d'accord avec
Emmanuel Macron regardez la réaction de
Manuel bonpard on était en attente
depuis un an que le Président de la
République dépose lui-même un projet de
loi constitutionnel et annonce ce matin
qui va le faire c'est une bonne nouvelle
je m'en réjouis et je rends hommage aux
associations notamment qui travaillent
sur cette question depuis des années qui
disent que dans le monde aujourd'hui le
droit à l'IVG est de plus en plus menacé
voilà pourquoi il y a une volonté
d'inscrire le droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution tout le monde a en tête le
cas des États-Unis hein il y a un an et
demi l'arrêt fédéral qui garantit le
droit à l'avortement a été annulé
résultat et bien l'avortement est
interdit dans un certain nombre d'États
depuis ce temps-là et donc inscrire la
Constitution ce droit dans la
Constitution en France ce serait une
manière de protéger le droit à
l'avortement contre tout recul de ce
type sauf que c'est une précaution qui
serait totalement inutile pour Marine Le
Pen même si elle n'y'est pas opposée
regardez ça quand même la beauté de
l'inutilité quoi on peut on peut se le
dire c'estàd que ça ne sert strictement
à rien de faire cela puisque aucun
mouvement politique
aucun qu'il soit à l'Assemblée nationale
ou qu'il soit en dehors ne demande la
remise en cause de l'IVG alors pourquoi
cette prise de position B parce qu'on
entend surtout que le principal risque
de remise en cause du droit à
l'avortement il pourrait venir de
l'arrivée au pouvoir d'un gouvernement
d'extrême droite conservateur donc
forcément Marine Le Pen elle refuse ce
procès d'intention qui V vise
indirectement son camp sans le nommer
mais une partie de la classe politique
ycpris à droite estime pourtant que le
risque est réel en France regardez une
dernière réaction celle de Xavier
Bertrand je sais que certains disent que
il y a pas de remise en cause du droit à
l'avortement dans notre pays aujourd'hui
mais je pense que c'est important de
disposer pour aujourd'hui pour demain et
pour après-demain et de reconnaître
cette liberté ce droit pour les femmes
dans notre pays donc l'inscription dans
la Constitution j'y suis favorable VO
donc dans l'ensemble
ite ça devit compqué de fairecrire ce
droit dans la constition ce sera pour
2024 maintenant ce qu'attendent les
défenseurs des droit c'est un calendrier
précis effectivement merci Samia c'est
très clair sur ce parcours législatif et
les réactions c'était nécessaire Yve
qu'Emmanuel Macron dise qu'il s'empare
de ce sujet et qu'il y aura un projet de
loi constitutionnel pour inscrire les VG
dans la Constitution c'est une promesse
qui lui coûte pas cher j'ai envie de
dire sincèrement c'est pas très
difficile ça va passer euh ça permet
aussi de pas s'éloigner de l'électorat
féminin me semble-t-il euh parce que
c'est aussi ça qui est derrière la tête
de de de Xavier Bertrand et d'autres
donc donc un calcul politique c'est ce
que vous nous non mais il y a pas c'est
vrai qu'il y a pas de risque il y avait
pas de risque que l'IVG soit remise en
cause ça peut se faire ça ça va se faire
sans sans sans problème et sans
polémique je l'espère en tous les cas
parce que si c'est le cas ça serait
grave euh on aimerait qu'il ait le même
courage pour d'autres le président de la
République pour d'autres textes
notamment celui sur euh l'immigration ou
sur d'autres fronts qui sont beaucoup
plus sensibles et où il n'arrêent pas de
tergiverser là bon il y a il je dirais
qu'il a il il occupe il occupe l'espace
public avec euh à à peu de
frais je pense que ça lui permet de
faire opser un petit clin d'œil en effet
du côté de la gauche euh vu qu'il l' pas
très la maltraiter avec la loi
immigration qui elle a beaucoup plus de
conséquences je regrette moi que ce soit
passé de Liber de de droit à liberté
parce que le droit c'est opposable et
que aujourd'hui la question pour l'IVG
dans le temps présent c'est la la
possibilité de le faire dans des délais
suffisamment rapprochés dans de bonnes
conditions ce qui n'est pas toujours le
cas et pas dans toutes les régions euh
voilà ça me semble le der mais là il a
choisi la version du Sénat qui est le
mot liberté absolument je voilà p plus
consensuel et que donc ça passera plus
facilement je je comprends bien je
comprends bien je peux néanmoins
regretter que voilà que droit est-
est-ce qu'il a eu raison ou est-ce qu'il
aurait dû reprendre la version de
l'assembl je pense que il fallait
trouver un compromis et que donc si ça
passait par liberté c'était astucieux
moi je crois que c'est important de
l'inscrire dans la Constitution parce
que Marine Le Pen a raison de dire
aujourd'hui qu'elle ne s'y oppose plus
mais on se souvient qu'il y a une
dizaine d'années elle parlait d'IVG de
confort et que tous les pays qui se
retrouvent où où se on retrouve avec la
remise en cause de ce droit ne s'y
attendait pas il y a 15 20 ans
c'estàdire que les Américaines par
exemple se retrouvent totalement surpris
de ce qui est en train de se passer on
ne sait pas comment les choses vont
évoluer donc je trouve que c'est une
question vraiment tellement fondamentale
pour la vie des femmes mais aussi pour
la vie des hommes que d'avoir un enfant
désiré et pour la vie des enfants à
naître que ça tout ça puisse bien se
passer qu' me semble que le protéger ça
me paraît être une mesure de bon sens
pour mais parce que pour vous cine un
risque de remise en cause de ce droit en
France ah ben écoutez moi je ne sais pas
de quoi demain sera fait véritablement
je veux dire quand encore une fois le
rassemblement national n'a pas toujours
eu cette position et du côté d'éc Zemour
Marion maréchal par exemple je ne sais
pas du tout quelle est sa position mais
vu les propos qu'elle tient qui sont
souvent très
extrêmes du point de vue de d'une
interprétation rigoriste de ce que
pourrait être la loi chrétienne ou la
foi chrétienne moi je n'en sais rien et
donc je trouve que c'est finalement vous
avez raison y de dire que ça ne lui
coûte pas très cher que c'est
probablement un calcul politique pour
les femmes pour la gauche quand il va
maltraiter la gauche mais en tout état
de cause bon ben je trouve que c'est
déjà ça de prix voilà ouais il y a un
risque de remise en cause quand même y
non mais c'est vrai que il y a il y a de
par le monde on voit il y a des
mouvements populistes des mouvements qui
sont parfois imprévisibles qui sont
aujourd'hui très prévisibles me
semble-t-il et qui ce qu'on appelle vous
savez des des régimes illibéraux c'estàd
qui remettent en
question certaines libertés certains
droits on le voit en Europe centrale on
le voit en Amérique en Amérique latine
on le voit aux États-Unis donc il faut
évidemment se méfier de tout ça en
Europe centrale j'ai dit ou Europe oui
oui mais même en Europe du Sud en fait
je veux dire l'Italie c'estz nous oui
mais donc c'est c'est pour ça qu'il faut
il faut être vigilant mais bon
sincèrement c'était pas l'urgence euh je
pense que l'urgence est largement
ailleurs elle est sur plusieurs fronts
économique elle est sur plusieurs fronts
sécuritaires euh et que là euh je trouve
que le le climat se dégrade il est grand
temps que euh le pays se reprenne et que
c'était certainement pas la priorité
ouais Marine Le Pen elle dit qu'elle
votera mais qu'effectivement c'est pas
la priorité c'est une démarche dit-elle
complètement un cont-temps de ce que
vivent les français moi je ne trouve pas
que ce soit pas la priorité de chercher
des points de consensus c'estàd je pense
que la position par exemple qui a pris
la France ces derniers temps pour
réaffirmer l'exigence par exemple de
deux une solution à deux états en
israël- Palestine c'est un point qui
fait consensus en France cette question
la fait consensus mais à la bon heure
qu'il y ait des endroits qu'il y ait des
moments où on soit d'accord tous
ensemble très largement et c'est le cas
pour la le droit à l'avortement moi il
me semble que on en a pas si souvent des
points d'accord et on va avoir un gros
point de désaccord qui arrive donc moi
je trouve que franchement dans le ce qui
va mal il y a pas que de
l'économicsocial qui va mal il y a pas
que du sécuritaire qui va mal ce qui va
mal c'est aussi notre vivre ensemble qui
va pas très bien l'autre argument qui
est avancé par la gauche c'est que la
France envoie un message aux autres pays
c'est-à-dire que même s'il n'y avait pas
de menace
identifié en France c'est une manière de
de pour tous les autres pays où ce droit
est menacé de d'affirmer que il faut le
protéger est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec cette il faudrait pas qu'on on ait
un discours euh enfin bon c'est assez
étonnant parce que on reproche tout le
temps à la France de donner les leçons à
la terre entière donc restons chez nous
euh moi je suis universaliste hein je
suis pas du tout euh pour un repli c'est
mais je dire on peut pas avoir deux
discours à la fois quoi quand on nous
reproche de faire la leçon à tout le
monde bon bah là occupons-nous déjà de
ce qu'on a à faire et puis ça ira
beaucoup mieux et je pense que d'abord
il faut qu'on s'occupe de nous parce
qu'on a vraiment des sujets brûlants
importants à traiter et avant d'aller
faire la leçon à tout le monde on se
fait dehors c'est ainsi que ça ça
se produit sur des terrain que je
connais bien en Afrique en Afrique du
Nord en Afrique subsaharienne et et
parfois ailleurs dans le monde donc
restons modeste regardons-nous regardons
notre évolution et avant de dire que la
France patrie des droits de l'homme des
lumières effectivement elle doit la
rester je l'entends bien mais euh je
pense pas que il faille qu'on légifère
tout le temps ou qu'on agisse tout le
temps avec cette référence à la en tête
comme c'est étonnant normalement vous
êtes plutôt l'héritier de la droite
gaulenne Gauliste non vous êtes plutôt
ben je pense que c'est à ce moment c'est
quand la France a été a porté un
discours au monde que elle a existé ce
n'est pas parce que c'est pas sa
puissance démographique ni sa puissance
économique qui l'a fait exister c'est
quand elle est capable ben moi c'est ce
que je dis c'est quand elle porte un
discours de paix quand elle porte un
discours pour les droits des femmes ou
quand elle porte un discours en faveur
de l'écologie je pense que c'est ça qui
peut lui donner en effet de l'influence
parce que encore une fois ce ce n'est
pas par ses petits bras musclés qu'elle
va influencer le monde par contre par
son soft power c'est par une politique
qui a du sens qui fait consensus en
France et l'écologie je pense que ferait
ferait un très beau consensus en France
si on était capable d'en discuter de
mettre sur la table des propositions qui
ne soi qui soi égal enfin qui soi
socialement accepable juste je pense que
voilà des sujets sur lequels on pourrait
je vous réliquer aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
même à Viller côteray il y a
l'inauguration d'une maison de la langue
française je m'en réjouis ah oui oui et
qui est invité est-ce que la la la
présidente la secrétaire générale de la
de la Francophonie est invité est-ce que
les les présidents de pays francophones
sont invités B sils ne le sont pas je ne
le sais pas mais si voilà là c un signal
non mais s'ils ne sont pas c'est une
faute ceci étant que le le le message
qui avait été qui a été donné par
Emmanuel Macron moi me satisfaisait
plutôt puisqu'il parlait de des langues
enfin de la façon de parler le français
dans le monde dans la diversité et du
fait qu'il y a des cultures en France
donc pour moi c'était plutôt pas mal
donc voilà je pense que la défense du
français je vous
réplique plus para un beau sujet domage
c'est dommage qu'on n pas invité vous
voyez tous les responsables des pays
francophone là c'était un beau signal je
veux je partage avec vous et ce que je
veux dire c'est que tous les sujets même
quand ils font consensus ne veulent pas
dire qu'il ne peut pas y avoir de débat
à l'intérieur du consensus on a parlé de
la liberté ou du droit on peut parler de
la façon dont doit évoluer le la façon
de parler le français ça aussi ça fait
partie du débat mais en tout cas je
pense que sur la défense du français il
me semble qu'il y a là aussi il y a une
base de consensus qu'il faudrait
travailler on va parler d'un sujet
beaucoup moins consensuel c'est le
projet de loi immigration qui arrive au
Sénat dans une semaine ce sera le 6
novembre prochain lundi et à une semaine
de l'examen du texte on a du mal à à
voir quel est le chemin quelle est la
porte de sortie pour le gouvernement
est-ce qu'un consensus est possible
iftra non parce que chacun campe sur des
positions qui sont des position je
dirais de principe et où justement
l'impossibilité de de trouver un
consensus est absolument terrible dans
un pays comme le nôtre sur des sujets
graves pour le coup alors c'est quoi le
l'impossibilité de trouver un consensus
d'abord on sait absolument pas à quoi
ressemble le contenu du projet de loi
est-ce que il y a cet article 3 sur la
régularisation
des travailleurs dans les métiers en
tension et sous quelles
conditions quelles sont les mesures on
en parle jamais de ça on parle tout le
temps de l'article 3 mais on parle
jamais des mesures qui facilitent ou qui
accélèent ou qui rendent plus efficaces
les obligations de quitter le territoire
qui sont un point mort de notre
législation puisque on on décide de
choses on on décide de choses et on
n'arrive pas à les mettre à exécution
donc voilà il y a il y a plein de choses
Gal il en parle c'est ce qui lui fait
dire que c'est le texte le plus ferme de
ces 20 oui est-ce que vous êtes capable
de me dire comment on va obliger les
gens à quitter le territoire de façon
plus efficace donc personne n'est
capable de le dire donc il il y a quand
même beaucoup de choses qui sont encore
en suspens et je pense que la la la la
communication du gouvernement parce
qu'il s'agit de communication autour de
ce texte a depuis été le depuis le début
a pas été bonne par parce que le
gouvernement a varié parce que le
gouvernement a changé de pied parce que
à l'intérieur de la majorité et bien il
n'y a pas un consensus
donc je suis assez inquet sur ce sujet
c'est un problème de
communication Catherine ou c'est un
problème de philosophie du texte le
gouvernement a voulu mettre un peu de
droite un peu de bah il y a les deux oui
moi je pense qu'il y a un problème de
communication mais fondamentalement il y
a un problème de de dysfonctionnement de
ce texte en effet parce qu'on veut
mettre un peu de tout parce que c'est le
29e texte en 40 ans qui arrive sur le
sujet donc on se demande bien pourquoi
il est nécessaire ensuite il ne règlera
évidemment pas la question de la
reconduite aux frontières puisque ce
n'est pas une question strictement de
mesures législatives il faut bien que
pour être reconduit à la frontière que
de l'autre côté il quelqu'un qui veut
bien vous accueillir et ça ça se règlera
pas de cette manière et ce que je pense
c'est que plus fondamentalement je pense
que c'est un un texte qui ne prend pas
la mesure du problème qui est devant
nous qui est que on va vers des
migrations très importantes euh dont on
on peut toujours s'imaginer qu'on va
construire des murs et des barrières
maintenant je veux pas faire de
parallèle hasard de mais on est quand
même maintenant on a compris que il n'y
a rien qui puisse empêcher
définitivement les hommes de passer donc
aujourd'hui la question est de penser le
monde qui vient qui est un monde dans
lequel l'ONU annonce qu'il y aura plus
de 1 milliard et demi de de de de
migrants dans les d'ici 2050 alors
l'essentiel des migrations vont pas
venir vers le nord elles vont être sud
sud c'est veut dire que c'est les pays
les plus pauvres qui vont devoir gérer
la question desmigration c'est déjà le
cas comme c'est déjà le cas et ça va
donc continuer ceci étant il est
illusoire de penser que le Nord n'aura
pas à accueillir des migrants et on ne
prend pas du tout cette questionl en
compte on n'y réfléchit pas on imagine
qu'on va pouvoir dresser des murs et des
protections et des barrières et on par
ailleurs on le fait au prix tout à
l'heure on parlait de Villar côteré de
notre influence je dirais dans le monde
et on le fait au prix de par exemple
refuser l'entrée des étudiants en France
étrangers alors que c'est allez évidence
une manière pour la France de rayonner
dans le monde à la fois économiquement
et culturellement donc je pense que
véritablement c'est un problème de
philosophie qui est anachronique C ce
projet de loi est anachronique en dehors
du fait qu'il est inutile parce que
c'est le 29e et que ça ne changera ça ne
changera rien sauf quelques mesures
complètement hallucinantes par exemple
que de retirer la couverture médicale
universelle qui n'a pas été introduite
uniquement par humanisme mais qui a été
aussi introduite par compréhension que
c'est parce que la population est
protégée et en senté que on n' pas des
maladies qui se propagent comme la
tuberculose comme c'était ça à l'origine
la préoccupation qui était en en
question mais comme on a pu le voir avec
le covid c'estàd qu'il y a besoin
d'avoir une population protégée si nous
ne voulons pas nous tous subir les
effets de cette moi je pense qu'il y a
urgence à
euh remettre tout à plat parce que
justement précisément et c'est un sujet
que qui m qui m'est cher euh on euh
ferme la porte à beaucoup de gens qui
devrai euh pouvoir venir dans notre pays
notamment des étudiants de certains pays
notamment des hommes euh et les femmes
qui ont des choses à faire chez nous de
de de du commerce ce qu'on veut et euh à
l'inverse on est en train de se euh de
se et ben de de diluer euh cette
priorité je dirais dans un magma
migratoire qui est gravissime je suis
désolé olé la générosité française elle
est réputée dans le monde entier et mais
bien sûr que vous connaissez mal
l'Afrique madame je vous invite à aller
avec moi en Afrique et vous allez voir
comment ça se passe vous allez voir
comment ça se passe pour moi c'est pas
un souvenir du tout j'y vais
régulièrement j'y retourne encore demain
d'ailleurs et bien vous vous vous verrez
que la la la France a de ce point de vue
une générosité qui pourrait être revu de
fond en comble de fond en comble il faut
revoir le modèle français de
social qui est un modèle je suis désolé
qui attire énormément les gens à
l'extérieur qui ont des besoins
évidemment parce que ce sont des gens
qui vivent dans des pays où il y a pas
justement toutes ces facilités et ils
veulent fuir la misère effectivement je
suis d'accord avec vous là où il faut
intervenir c'est aussi dans non pas le C
enfin le céveloppement si vous voulez il
faut arrêter avec la coopération parce
que la coopération a des connotations
qui sont dépassées mais il faut effectiv
tivement revoir probablement nos
systèmes de coéveloppement nos
politiques de céveloppement avec les
pays qui en ont besoin mais il faut
complètement revoir les moyens d'accès à
notre pays qui sont je
dirais
utilisé de façon excessive et sans qu'on
contrôle quoi que ce soit et moralité on
arrive avec une avec des gens qui sont
dans notre pays qui ne sont pas intégrés
qu'onarrive pas intégré et c'est pas un
système pour reprendre un pour reprendre
un vocabulaire que j'aime pas beaucoup
mais c'est pas un système gagnant
gagnant parce que l'immigré qui n'est
pas accueilli comme il le faut et ben il
vit dans la plus grande des détresses ça
vous pouvez pas le nier c'est horrible
c'est horrible de voir ce qui se passe
dans certains quartiers pas uniquement
de Paris d'ailleurs mais de toutes les
grandes villes de France et puis et bien
ça disloque je dirais le système nation
d'accueil du public et je trouve que là
il y a beaucoup de choses àir bon c'est
exactement ce que je disais c'estàd
qu'en fait il n'y a pas de réflexion sur
la politique d'accueil
c'est il y a pas donc c'est c'est de ça
dont il
s'agit et par ailleurs et par ailleurs
vous ne pouvez pas dire que la France
est généreuse je veux dire elle ne prend
pas sa part des Mig des migrants qui
arrivent en Italie tout le monde le sait
elle ne distribue plus de visas y
compris de visas de tourisme pour les
familles enfin moi j'ai plein d'exemples
mais nous avons tous des tas d'exemples
d'Algériens de Marocains qui ne peuvent
pas venir les les les petits enfants Les
grands-parents ne peuvent pas se revoir
enfin je veux dire on sait très bien et
on vient de parler de la fermeture des
des visas pour les étudiants étrangers
de toute la p de de l'Afrique noire
centrale enfin je veux dire tout ça est
absolument euh ça ça ne va pas du tout
et par contre on roule des mécaniques
sur des mesures absurdes qui rassurent
je ne sais qui si imaginez que faire en
sorte que les gens ne puissent plus se
soigner quand ils sont en France je ne
vois pas qui ça rassure chez les
Français et évidemment pas chez les
migrants et par ailleurs transformer
l'aide médicale d'État en aide médicale
d'urgence restreindre l'aide méd ex
c'estàd qu'on ne peut plus se faire
soigner de toutes les maladies qui vous
arrivent quand vous êtes sur le
territoire français aide médicale d'État
qui actuellement est utilisé que par
un/ers des migrants c'est qu'en plus ce
sont des droits qui ne sont pas connus
quand je dis qu'il y a un problème
d'accueil c'est qu'en fait cette
politique là elle n'est même pas mise en
si aussi longtemps que aussi longtemps
qu'on aura pas réglé et remis à plat
toute cette politique euh on va au
devant de de graves problèmes vous
l'avez dit effectivement par exemple la
population africaine va passer à 2
milliards 500 millions d'habitants d'ici
à 2050 et il est urgent effectivement de
remettre à plat notre système de notre
politique migratoire parce que c'est une
politique qui est faite de brick et de
broc c'est une politique de gribouille
c'est une qui est profondément injuste
parce que elle elle n'est pas ouverte
justement aux gens qui devraient pouvoir
s'installer ou venir provisoirement sur
notre territoire et donc tout ça il faut
le revoir je je trouve ça hallucinant
qu'on se satisfasse de voir des camps de
migrants sur notre territoire avec des
gens dont on sait pertinemment que
jamais on arrivera à les
intégrer c'est une
honte moi je pense pas je pense pas
comme vous ils vont s'intégrer vont
intégré mais à quel prix ils ne
partiront pas c'est plutôt ça dont on
peut être certain du coup est-ce qu'un
accord est possible ou pas avec les
républicains hier dans le Parisien
Olivier marlex alors qui est le patron
des députés disait Gérald harmanin mon
français c'est un texte avec de fausses
mesures de droite sans effet et des
vraies mesures de gauche non mais c'est
pasz faut arrêter ce vocabulaire de vrai
de gauche droite est-ce que c'est un
texte efficace ou pas moi je ne peux pas
juger tant que je ne l'ai pas ce texte
je n'ai pas vu le texte en en soi le
texte l'article 3 par exemple il
ressemble à quoi quelles sont les
conditions qui font que vous régularisez
certains salariés parce que j'ai compris
que c'était pas tous les clandestins
c'est une partie des clandestins mais
lesquels dans quelles conditions comment
vous fait il faut avoir il faut avoir
été présent sur le territoire il faut
avoir travailler 8 mois les 24 derniers
mois les
ocut comment comment vous comment vous
ex comment vous exécutez les les ocutf
c'est c'est c'est une chose que j'ai
toujours pas comprise
euh de façon efficace effectivement il y
a aussi l'histoire des pass laisser
passer consulaire parce que si on dit
bon bah on va rendre plus efficace les
TF mais d'accord mais est-ce que pour
autant il y aura les les laisser passer
consulaires qui vont enfin vous voyez il
y a autant de choses qui sont
complètement dans le flou donc je suis
incapable de vous dire si ça va être une
mesure efficace ou pas ou si ça va être
de la cosmétique comme trop souvent en
politique moi je ne vois pas ce qu'il y
a comme mesure de goû je vous le dis
très franchement on présente toujours
l'article 3 comme une mesure de gauche
pour moi c'est une mesure assez unique
c'estàd qu'en vérité je ne comprends pas
que l'on traite la question des hommes
et de leur
intégration sur le plan de l'utilité
c'est les hommes seraient donc jugés à
l'ône de leur utilité économique pour
moi c'est
absolument inhumain ce ce n'est pas
conforme à notre tradition humaniste et
je dirais ce n'est pas conforme au
discours du Pape François ouais mais
alors justement parce que vous parlez de
l'article 3 c'est le point de tension on
va écouter ce qu'on disait ce matin
Gérald invité de la matinale de BFM et
vous gardez cet article 3 je suis
évidemment très attaché au fait de pas
confondre tout et n'importe quoi les
deux mes deux grands-parents sont venus
de l'autre côté de la Méditerrané
travailler dans les mines pour l'un dans
l'armée pour l'autre voilà il répète
qu'il est très attaché à l'article 3
géraldin est-ce que du coup ça m fait en
suspense et il y aura pas de compromis
avec les
républicains je pense qu'il n aura pas
de compromis avec les républicains les
les républicains sur un plan strictement
politique n ont pas intérêt il est là le
sujet c'est que on a un sujet de fond
qui est un sujet important
mais vous avez des postures qui sont des
postures opportunistes qui sont des
postures électorales qui sont des
postures partisanes est-ce que les
républicains ont intérêt à faire ce
cadeau parce que c'est vraiment ça au
gouvernement je crois pas donc donc 493
donc 493 vous avez Madame Le Pen hier si
j'ai bien compris disait oui oui on
pourrait voter cette petite loi mais on
oublie de dire pas l'article dit voilà
enfin encore une fois l'article 3 pour
moi c'est présenté comme une mesure de
gauche et ça n'en est pas une moi je
crois en effet qu'il n'y aura pas
d'accord sur cet article là est-ce que
le gouvernementement ira jusqu'à faire
passer ça au 493 ça me paraît quand même
un peu hasardeux parce qu'il y a quand
même la menace pendante d'avoir une
motion de censure qui serait déposée par
les républicains ou une parti des
républicains et qui pourrait faire la
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale euh bon
je j'ai l'impression que on est parti
sur un truc qui n'a pas de sens et qui
peut déboucher sur une crise politique
majeure et qui peut déboucher sur rien
du tout ben on suivra ça qui n pas ah
moi c'est ce que je crois le plus
probable on suivra ça toute la semaine
et la semaine prochaine vous l'avez
compris le Tex arrive au Sénat lundi
prochain on termine en regardant ce
qu'elle de V journaux
[Musique]
régionaux et Samia c'est la tempête
Céline qui fait la une des journaux dans
l'ouest de la France oui le Bassin
d'Arcachon écop rapporte ce matin
Sud-Ouest au Cap Ferré le village
austricle de claué est sous les eau un
spectacle aussi inquiétant que magique
raconte un habitant la tempête Céline a
aussi frappé la Loire Atlantique il faut
maintenant penser les PL titre
aujourd'hui press-océan qui nous emmène
à pornique où les commerces ont été
inondés dans le sud c'est le cillassage
du bus de l'Olympique Lyonnais qui fait
les titres ce matin il a honte s'insurge
ce matin la Provence qui publie la photo
du visage de Fabio grossseo en sang hier
l'entraîneur de l'Olympique Lyonnais a
été blessé dans le caillassage de son
bus à Marseille avant une rencontre avec
l'OM quelle honte dénonce aussi le
progrès dans les mêmes termes où l'on
peut voir la photo du bus en question
avec une vitre totalement brisée suite à
cet incident bien évidemment le match
prévu entre les liyonnais et les
Marseillais a été reporté en isè on
s'inquiète pour la récolte de noix cette
année oui le dauphinet relais ce matin
le cri d'alarme des nuiculteurs les
producteurs de noix cette année oui on
apprend un mot tous les jours he dans la
revue de presse cette année la récolte
pourrait être divisée par trois la faute
à de mauvaises conditions météo la
saison passée était déjà catastrophique
le sort s'acharne raconte le journal où
l'on peut lire les tmignage de
producteurs qui craignent le pire pour
leur exploitation cette année et on
termine sur le dépannage à domicile
c'est dans la Dépêche du Midi oui gare
aux arnaques prévient le journal
serérruriers plombiers électricien on en
a peut-être déjà tous fait l'expérience
64 % des sociétés sont en infraction
d'après une enquête de la répression des
fraudes prestation baclé surfacturation
La Dépêche du Midi passe en vue toutes
les mauvaises pratiques et donne des
conseils pour éviter de se faire avoir
merci Samia merci beaucoup la Une du
Figaro c'est Gaza Israël lance la deième
phase de son offensive bah oui c'est le
la la la poursuite de la de l'offensive
israélienne qui maintenant enfin depuis
ce weekend est une offensive aussi
terrestre et maritime et la une de la
revue regard Catherine c'est le climat
la science peut-elle sauver l'humanité
oui on pose la question et on a une
réponse qui est qui est il y aura pas de
solution sans la science mais la science
ne suffira pas bon c'est à lire dans la
revue regarde merci catherrine TR merci
trèard d'avoir été avec nous merci Samia
nous on se retrouve demain merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi et à 18h vous avez
rendez-vous avec pour s public très
bonne journée à
demain